first person who ever traveled to the
North Pole did so because of like a bar
bet that went too far he was a Salesman
in Minnesota in 1968 and he was obsessed
with snowmobiles couldn't stop talking
about him so much so that his friends
were like if you love snowmobiles so
much why don't you travel to the North
Pole with one challenge accepted and
let's be clear getting to the North Pole
which is just a frozen ocean is
incredibly difficult many people had
tried it and failed over the years and
yes people had been there with airplanes
and submarines and stuff but no one had
ever like just traveled across the
frozen ice and got into the North Pole
but this guy did it so this guy sets out
with like a couple of his buddies on
this 800 mile Journey this is a frozen
ocean with moving ICE that creates like
potholes that go into the Arctic Ocean
these big ridges made from Ice oh yeah
and there's polar bears he got sponsors
for this he even had like a documentary
crew follow him in like an airplane like
dropping resupply it was kind of like a
big red bull stunt but before Red Bull
so yeah he's the one who holds the
record on getting to the North Pole
first this like random salesman from
Minnesota